cinq bougies pour les enfants de la
terre l'association humanitaire de marie
claire et yannick noah fête son
cinquième anniversaire avec une série de
manifestations pendant une semaine des
spectacles des matches de tennis ou de
rugby pour recueillir des fonds pour les
enfants en détresse ce lancement des
festivités cet après midi avec les
spectacles ian hervier eric roumanie un
joli conte musical pour donner le coup
d'envoi d'une série de manifestations
organisées par la fondation les enfants
de la terre depuis cinq ans
l'association de yannick noah se
mobilisent pour les enfants dans la
détresse
trois maisons surnommé maison tendresse
les accueillent sans distinction
d'origine de race ou de maladie ce ne
sont pas des colonies de vacances sont
pas des foyers ce sont des maisons
ouvertes toute l'année à tout enfant qui
en a besoin dans cet homme - peu vaste
c'est à dire qu'on travaille avec les
hôpitaux paris et vous pouvez un jour
voir deux ou trois enfants malades ou le
lendemain vous pouvez voir des enfants
de la das du ministère de la justice
une troisième fois vous allez voir un
groupe d'enfants envoyé par une
municipalité des enfants qui ne vont
jamais en vacances et ses enfants notre
but c'est de les faire se retrouver
ensemble qu'il n'y ait pas à chaque fois
que des malades ou que des enfants de
telle ou telle région que tous ces
enfants se retrouvent tous ensemble
d'autres manifestations sont prévues
notamment mardi au stade de clichy
soirée football avec platini giresse
jeudi rugby avec blanco et enduro point
d'orgue de cette semaine ils font des
tennis au palais des sports de pavie
avec tous les copains ou de yannick noah
manifestation donc à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle façon
de mobiliser le public
on essaie de faire ce qu'on peut d'avoir
pendant un moment c'était il suffit de
faire quelques matches de tennis et puis
on avait de quoi renflouer les caisses
pour faire vivre ces maisons maintenant
on essaye de faire participer un peu
d'autres gens alors on a des amis dans
différents sports est maintenant un peu
dans la musique
et effectivement il ya eu 7 ce spectacle
pour les gosses cet après-midi ensuite
il ya ce match de foot à clichy mardi
jeudi un match de rugby avec mes copains
du showbiz et tout ça nous devons et
puis samedi on a eu un spectacle au
palais des sports de porte de versailles
avec des joueurs de tennis mcenroe vie
dans des villas c'est moi et ensuite un
concert on va se retrouver sur scène
accompagné d'autres copains jocelyne
beroard sa fille pauline ester et puis
j'ai en mixant son bras justement vous
êtes aussi beaucoup de stars à votre
action pour votre association
c'est une façon donner du rêve aussi
pour les enfants que vous aider et vous
avez été frappé par par la tristesse de
ses enfants c'est pour ça que voulez
vous nous direz mais écoutez la
tristesse il y en a toujours surtout
dans les hôpitaux et je crois que ces
enfants droit même au même titre que les
autres arrivées un peu et c'est vrai
dans les hôpitaux c'est issa peu
difficile des fois et quand on y va on
est touchés parce qu'on se rend compte
que la télévision un tel pouvoir que ces
gosses qui nous voient à la télé dans un
ter ne retrouve comme ça devant ils sont
tout d'un coup avant magique
le docteur me dise que c'est beaucoup
plus facile de soigner ses enfants alors
bon on les retrouve des fois dans nos
maisons
c'est vrai que ça fait toujours plaisir
en plus de voir qu'il ya d'autres
copains qui s'investissent avec nous
donc on a tout mis qui toute la semaine
avait plein de gens j'ai à peu près une
centaine de personnes vous aider vous
avez déclaré que justement celui qui
envoie un chèque nous intéresse pas
autant que celui qui se déplace que
peuvent faire les gens le public qui me
regarde par exemple ce soir s'ils
veulent participer
on a besoin d'un d'échec bien sûr parce
que ces maisons et villas avec l'échec
mais ce qui est important surtout c'est
l'état d'esprit dans lequel on fait quoi
et c'est vrai que très souvent lorsqu'on
arrive sur dans certains endroits et
confirma le tennis et que ensuite on
projette un film pour expliquer un peu
ce qu'on fait avec les enfants de la
terre les gens sont surpris et et là
commence à participer vraiment
s'intéresser aux causes que peuvent-ils
faire par exemple mahe maison que vous
avez mises a mis sur place il ya des
gens qui peuvent venir
des gens qui viennent au bureau à son
nom la bretèche là nous nous aider alors
on est on est ouvert à tous parce que
l'épreuve est bien là toujours là et
prem
on a besoin de gens qui nous aide sur le
plan humain on a besoin de gens qui nous
donnent du matériel on a besoin aussi
d'argent on a besoin de gens qui
participent quoi roland garros et dans
une semaine quand vous aviez gagné le
tournoi il ya 11 ans vous aviez après
avoir gagné le tournoi
vous aviez un petit peu parlé parlé du
vide dans votre existence cette
association c'était une façon un petit
peu donner un sens à votre vie ben on
cherche toujours un peu le sens de la
vie et c'est vrai que quelque part je me
suis aperçu que donner cette année très
bien la réponse est je prends beaucoup
de plaisir à le faire à participer à ce
genre de choses qui sont à la télévision
on voit des images assez difficile
surtout quand ça touche les gosses
et puis quand on se dit qu'on peut
participer à quelque chose qu'on peut
faire partie d'une association ou autre
chose à avoir cette générosité un peu
comme style de vie je crois que c'est
une bonne chose et moi je suis content
de pouvoir le faire
je suis content que samassa le rendez
vous à tout le monde à l'éden roc et
quelle place occupe les tennis
aujourd'hui dans votre avis balotelli je
joue beaucoup moi et puis quand je
jouais ya plus la télé quoi mais je joue
toujours un peu et puis quand on a vécu
vingt temps là dedans on s'en sort pas
comme ça il ya toujours une belle façon
qui reste bien sûr l'actualité votre
actualité maintenant bientôt un disque
bien je vais rentrer en studio cet été
donc on commence à travailler
tranquillement un disque en français
cette fois
bah il faut bien mais faut bien que je
raconte un peu les choses en français et
puis des projectiles et va peut-être
avait parlé un petit peu dernièrement
oui il ya des choses je des projets
notamment un qui m'intéresse beaucoup et
qu'il se peut que ça se fasse dans le
conte année prochaine
concrètement quel est ce projet baptisé
puisse aider que j'en saurai un peu plus
mais l'a pour l'instant ça en est où
au stade du projet ça m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est l'histoire qui qui fait
partie des choses que j'ai envie de dire
quoi c'est à dire un message beaucoup de
la tolérance un peu plus de l'humanité
c'est un rôle qu'il ya de l'humanité
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas de couleur
et c'est quelqu'un qui a du coeur un
dernier mot justement votre barre votre
nouveau look c'est juste une question de
luz est aussi 100 brasse aussi ma part
je vous demande pas la barbe ma barre
demandant ce que je veux faire beaucoup
de bateaux et j'ai pas j'ai pas le temps
de me raser
merci beaucoup les emplois d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
alors pour tout renseignement sur le
challenge des enfants de la terre donc
cette série de manifestations la semaine
prochaine elle numéro de téléphone le 34
62 07 07
et je signale qu'il reste des places
pour la manifestation de samedi prochain
au palais des sports dont vous parliez